التفوق الجوي الروسي هو ما يكبر الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد ياسف الرئيس الاوكراني
مما وصفه بالتباطؤ والتقاعس الغربي عن مد
الجيش الاوكراني بالدعم العسكري الكافي
لاحداث تكافؤ بين القوتين
ترى سنه عسكريه تمنح روسيا الهيمنه الجويه
وهي ميزه تشتكي منها كييف باستمرار وتريد
تسويتها والحقيقه ان العدد الدقيق
والقدرات التشغيليه للقوات الجويه الروسيه
هي بالطبع سر عسكري لكن مارك ميلي رئيس
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه افصح بان الروس
يمتلكون مئات من مقاتلات الجيلين الرابع
والخامس تستخدم القوات الجويه الروسيه في
ساحه المعركه باوكرانيا قنابل ذكيه زينتها
500 كجم مزوده بانظمه يو ام بي كي وهي ذات
قدره تدميريه عاليه تلعب المروحيات
الروسيه من طراز كي اي
المجهزه بصواريخ موجهه دورا حاسما في صد
الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني فقد استطاعت هذه
المروحيات تدمير دبابات الالمانيه
والمركبات المضره الاوكرانيه اما
المقاتلات الروسيه من طراز سوخوي 30 اس ام
وسخوي 24 فقد كشف انها تشكل تهديدا
للاسطول الاوكراني ودمرت زوارق الانزال
الاوكرانيه تعمل روسيا على تكريس السيطره
على اجواء المعركه من خلال طائرات اي 50
التي تقوم بالاستطلاع وتحديد الاهداف بما
في ذلك الطائرات المسيره تمتلك روسيا
مقاتلات قادره على اسقاط اف 16 بنجاح خاصه
35 المقاتل الثقيله التي تمتلك قدرات
عاليه وكذلك الطائره الاعتراضيه بعيده
المدى ميغ 31 المخصصه لاطلاق صواريخ
كينجال والتي استخدمت لتدمير بطاريات
باتروت فيكي
اضافه الى منظومات الدفاع الجوي خاصه
منظومه اس 400
تطلب كييف من الغرب عتادا يمكنها من كسر
هذه المعادله التي تظهر تفوقا روسيا
وبالنظر الى ساحه المعركه فانه رغم تفوق
روسيا على اوكرانيا من حيث القدرات الجويه
فان موسكو لم تستطع بعد عام ونصف من
القتال حسب الحرب ذلك ان ما يحدث بين
روسيا واوكرانيا صراع جو ارض وفق الخبراء
العسكريين يطلبوا زيلينسكي تحديدا 160
طائره اف 16 يرى ان هذا العدد من
المقاتلات الامريكيه الصنع هو القادر على
تحدي التفوق الروسي في الجو وكانت كييف قد
تسلمت من الغرب ثلاث منظومات دفاع جوي
متقدمه وهي منظومه ناسيمز المصنعه بشكل
مشترك بين الولايات المتحده والنرويج
ومنظومه ايرس تيال الالمانيه المضاده
للطائرات ومنظومه من احدث اسلحه الدفاع
الجوي لدى الولايات المتحده وتبادل
الانتقادات بين كييف والغرب بشان الدعم
العسكري الجوي يذكر بح لقات سابقه ابان
طلب الجيش الاوكراني دبابات ابرز
الامريكيه ولبرد الالمانيه ومؤخرا احجام
برلين عن امدادكييف بصواريخ كروز خشيه
اطلاقها لضرب اهداف داخل روسيا بينما
تتردد الاداره الامريكيه في منح الضوء
الاخضر لامداد اوكرانيا بصواريخ ارض ارض
من نوع
[موسيقى]